and we make way for broossooli who joins
us now 105.7 the zone morning host and
he joins us now what's the latest Bruce
in Columbus well I think nationally you
know they're being made fun of for that
rally last night and I think locally
there are a lot of Ohio State fans are
like holy cow I'm not really sure I want
those signs to speak for me last night
if somebody made a play on the me to
movement and supporting Urban Meyer so
it was a bad look I would love to know
the percentage of people there last
night who actually have Ohio State
degrees I think the percentage might be
higher of people who were there last
night who have a dog named Brutus so I
didn't go well and I thought it could
only have the potential to hurt Urban
Meyer and if your administration you're
looking at that you're thinking holy cow
they're only like a hundred people they
care if we did anything to Urban Meyer I
don't know if there's a cooling-off
period if that's really what everybody
needs here including Urban Meyer but I'm
just watching yesterday and and their
vitriol was pointed towards ESPN like
how can they be upset with ESPN in this
situation Bruce well look there's a lot
of effort going on right now Dan to do
anything people can do to discredit any
piece of this story and there's a lot of
you know smear campaigns going on about
the ex-wife of the former wide receivers
coach a lot of smear campaign going on
against Brett McMurphy's reporting and
all that minutia is so irrelevant to the
real question that matters and the
question that matters is did something
happen with an Ohio State coach an
assistant coach that put a situation in
front of Urban Meyer if the answer to
that is yes then all your attention
ought to be from this point on did Evan
Meyer handle it right and did gene Smith
the athletic director handle it right
there's more than enough evidence that
something happened that that situation
was presented to them and I'm convinced
that committee will be focusing its
attention entirely on how Urban Meyer
and his supposed superiors handled it
not minutiae about any thing that went
on in a very
blouson marital relationship or how
those details were reported
now you sent this out that they're
interviewing witnesses today I now think
that he might skate with noting that
their committee investigation will show
surprise we looked at everything and did
everything right still have to handle
why he kept a likely abuser on his staff
for three years they'll probably kick
that aside and say no charges were filed
do you think that's how this plays out
at Ohio State I think it is a
possibility for how it plays out I think
that they're not going to come out and
fire Dean Smith over this the athletic
director they're certainly not going to
come out and take a university position
vilifying the victim of the domestic
violence so I think it is possible that
they could come out and say hey look we
looked nothing to see here
urban handled everything just like he
should have and then the question will
be well why did you keep Zach Smith on
the staff and your only answer to that
one that is plausible is there were no
charges filed yeah that was still the
puzzling part of this that you even if
charges aren't filed you know why does
Urban Meyer or does he get pressure from
his wife to say why are you keeping him
on your staff when I've been in touch
with you know his ex-wife like that's
what that's still the puzzling part here
Bruce yeah we all but Dan you know he
was Earl Bruce's grandson if he's not a
real versus grandson he's not there it's
not a good enough reason that's why we
keep wanting to look for another reason
we want to find like some nugget of
truth here but truth only really has
value in matters like this when it's
something you can weaponize against
someone you don't like like we require
in our families we require truth from
our kids or truth from our spouse or
truth of our co-workers but really now
in where we are in sports and everywhere
else you only value truth if you can use
it against somebody if you're if you're
a Democrat you want to you know snark
will build a wall in Mexico pay for it
if you're a Republican you want to snark
I can keep your doctor if you like your
doctor you can keep your doctor
Ohio State fans require honesty of Jim
Harbaugh if hardball did this they'd be
all over him he lied in Chicago Buckeye
fans they don't require honesty from
Urban Meyer Michigan fans required from
Urban Meyer so it's a really weird
the people that we embrace in the public
space we don't require honesty from them
we require it from the people we don't
like so we can use it against them as a
club a week ago a lot of people thought
that urban was going to be fired
foregone conclusion here is their chance
that he skates you know kind of punish
punishment free penalty free no
suspension I give a 0% chance to him
being fired now I give a 50% chance he
gets a two-game suspension and I give a
50% chance that he gets nothing because
the longer you wait on this you sort of
find other avenues out and their avenue
out is hey look we did everything right
we do care about domestic violence and
we took it seriously and you know what
Dan that may in fact have happened but
urban just positioned himself so poorly
in Chicago with his repeated lies about
questions that for he had the truth on
his side he didn't know yeah I fired the
guy because we had this thing and we
can't have it in our program and so this
rally last night is even more curious
because they're rallying in support of
the guy who created this situation yeah
that's what I wanted to see like a sign
that just said you know zachsmith shame
on you you put coach Urban Meyer in this
situation like just something that was
honest and truthful here Urban Meyer
doesn't need that support Urban Meyer is
gonna herbin Meyer is gonna be fine in
my opinion I just didn't think it was a
good look for Ohio State fans because
you know you're calling out ESPN I think
ESPN hit the pause button in reporting
this Bruce trying to protect Urban Meyer
maybe they're gonna say they wanted to
get all their information first before
they did it but I you know I'm not
vilifying anybody at ESPN and the guy
who did report this initially doesn't
work for ESPN that's why I didn't
understand that I know I mean ESPN got
beat on the college football story of
the year so far by a guy that they got
rid of in a cost-cutting move so Brett
McMurphy is not responsible for this
Courtney Smith's not responsible for
this ESPN is certainly not responsible
for this I would argue that the reason
Urban Meyer is on paid administrative
leave is because Aaron Meyer chose
willing
to lie when he had at least 16 hours
notice he was going to be asked about
Zack Smith he could have told a truth
given a true representation of the facts
as he's presenting them now I turned it
in to my superiors I told Zack if
anything ever happened related to this
ever again he was gone
we're moving on to football we are not
going to have this in our program and I
think it'd be over and he'd be coaching
but he's not and I think he will be soon
but the reason he's not is guy looking
back in the mirror from her admirer your
co-host in the morning is Chris Spielman
one of the great Buckeyes of all time
how does he feel about this well he's a
lot more forgiving of Urban's lying in
Chicago than I am and I credit that to
the fact that Chris has a much more
close relationship with urban they work
together in the booth at ESPN it's no
different than you or I we would forgive
somebody we know well or that we love in
our family because our relationship is
closer to them
urban is a guy who he's close to Chris
because Chris has earned his respect by
excelling in the world that urban is in
if you're a football player a two-time
all-american at Ohio State and a
distinguished player in the NFL then I
tend to think Urban's got a much higher
degree of respect for you than he did
for the guys in Chicago who were asking
him questions I really think the reason
he lied in Chicago and I don't know that
he'll ever admit this is because I think
there's a certain amount of urban up
there thinking who are you guys to
question me why would I let you see the
dirty laundry in my program and it's one
of those cases where the coach's ego and
dismissive nature of people looking into
what he does and how he does it got him
into trouble
good stuff Bruce thank you we appreciate
your time thank you any time that's
Bruce hooli he's one of the morning host
on 105.7 the zone the Fox affiliate that
that show pre seats are crispy almond is
his co-host there for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
you